[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
Bible related question give us a call
now at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor
hi friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
a used book typically costs less than a
new one that's of course unless the book
is written by Leonardo da Vinci and is
the only one in existence
in 1994 Microsoft Creator Bill Gates
purchased the Codex Lester a 72-page
leather-bound notebook written by the
Renaissance genius at Christie's Auction
House for a 30.8 million dollars
adjusted for inflation today that would
be about 54.4 million making it the most
expensive book in the world
created in 1510 the Codex Blaster
contains a broad spectrum of Da Vinci
scientific observations theories and
drawings on things like the movement of
water astronomy and why fossils of sea
creatures can be found on mountains
incredibly Da Vinci wrote the whole book
in mere writing or in other words
everything was deliberately written
backwards so it can only be easily read
with a mirror
you know when I first saw this pastor
Ross online I thought well they posted
this backwards and I took my Photoshop
copy and I flipped it around when I used
it in a sermon illustration now I
realize that's how it was written
backwards
you know the Bible tells us that there's
another Priceless book that can only be
written with special Assistance or only
red I should say with special assistance
that's right pastor and of course we're
talking about the Bible and talking
about expensive manuscripts uh doubtless
probably the most costly manuscript
available would be the Dead Sea Scrolls
building built around that so of course
the Bible is right up there with very
important documents but when you say
there's a special uh book that needs
help in order to understand it well when
we study the Bible we need the help of
the Holy Spirit yeah it tells us that
holy men spoke as they were moved by the
holy spirit so if the author is the holy
spirit certainly the Holy Spirit can
help us understand it Paul said in First
Corinthians 2 14
but the natural man does not receive the
things of the spirit of God for their
foolishness to him nor can he know them
because they are spiritually discerned
spiritual things are spiritually
discerned and you can read where Jesus
said in John 16 13. however when he the
spirit of Truth has come he will guide
you into all Truth for he will not speak
on his own authority but whatever he
hears he will speak and he will tell you
things to come
so this reminds us that when we open our
Bibles to study and when we open a
program like this to do our best to
answer questions
it's a holy spirit that really gives us
wisdom and understanding the Bible
speaks of needing the holy spirit to
guide us and uh it's always good to
start with prayer so let's do that pass
today dear father we are so grateful for
the opportunity that we have once again
to be able to open your word and study
we recognize this as a special book
divinely inspired and we ask for the
holy spirit to guide us here in the
studio be with those who are listening
and lead us to a clearer understanding
of Bible Truth for we ask this in Jesus
name amen amen we do have a study guide
Friends that talk about the Bible how
can you understand the Bible and how the
Holy Spirit can reveal truth to you it's
called is there anything left you can
trust one of the amazing facts study
guides if you'd like to receive it the
number to call is
800-835-6747 you'll see that number on
your screen if you're watching or you
can just simply dial pound 250 with your
smartphone if you're here in North
America say Bible answers live and then
ask for that free offer is there
anything left you can trust we'll be
happy to send that to anyone here in
North America in the U.S and if you're
outside of North America just go to the
Amazing Facts website just
amazingfacts.org and you'll be able to
learn more at the website
well Pastor Doug I think we're ready to
go to the phone lines this is a live
program friend so if you have a Bible
question the phone line here at the
studio is
800-463-7297 that'll bring your call
into Bible answers live we've been away
for the last week or so but it's good to
have another Live program so yes phone
lines are open first caller that we have
is Jerry listening in Texas Jerry you on
the air
a fantastic Pastor barash yes I am
and your question
okay guys this you referred to on April
22 when you had that had that panel when
you were up in Sacramento
when man walked the Earth with Dinosaurs
the Bible mentions such huge creatures
in the Book of Psalms 104
26. my question is were the levoxons
dinosaurs and venomous snakes a result
of amalgamation of nature
all right well the Bible does speak of a
couple of mysterious beasts one is the
Leviathan and the other is the behemoth
and uh I think that the um
uh the Behemoth some people have
Associated that with something that was
some dinosaur-like creature because it
talks about this huge beast and you
might think well was that a rhino or an
elephant but then it says its tail is
like a cedar tree well that creates a
different description uh anatomically
that would not fit with an elephant or a
rhino or something maybe a little Tails
and so but many dinosaurs based on the
paleontology had very big Tails so some
have wondered is it describing some
brontosaurus like Mighty beasts and it
very well may be were they created by
amalgamation now for friends listening
amalgamation is sort of when you cross a
breed you mix or amalgamate two
different species to try to make
something else that could end up
becoming monstrous
and you know there's nothing in the
Bible that tells us that dinosaurs are
the product of amalgamation
did people back in ancient times seek to
cross breed and amalgamate I'm talking
about within species
uh yeah
one reason I I say that is
Goliath it tells us you know he had some
brothers and Sons one of them had 24
digits meaning he had six fingers on
each head and six toes on each foot and
doctors tell us that often comes from
inbreeding and it could be the
Philistines were saying let's breed an
army of giants
and uh you know adol Hitler was trying
to do that get a super race
um a pit bull you might say is something
of an amalgamation it's the very
selective breeding of a dog and they
originally bred to fight in pits that's
where they get the name so where were
they breeding dinosaurs to get these
reptiles it doesn't say in the Bible
were there dinosaurs that lived
contemporaneous with humans yes
and then of course the flood has
something to do with it yeah that's why
we got the um we've got all the remains
that we can find in the earth of these
massive dinosaurs yes all right thank
you for your call we've got Gary by the
way Jerry you know amazing facts pardon
me Pastor Ross uh we have a a book it's
actually a comic book when I say comic
book it's Illustrated so we call it a
comic book but it's actually pretty
informative and it's about dinosaurs and
did they live in ancient times by Jim
pinkowski and he can go to the bookstore
and he'll find a copy of that okay we've
got Gary listening in Illinois Gary
welcome to Bible answers live
my question is about Revelation 12 17.
it says who keep the Commandments of God
and have the testimony of Jesus Christ
and so am I right to assume that the
Commandments aren't the only thing that
we're given to do but to to the
testimony would mean to give witness
about Jesus and why he's our salvation
that we're called not just to keep
commands but according to Revelation 12
17 also be a witness
you know that's a great question uh
you're very wise to see that there are
two distinct things that are mentioned
there talks about the Commandments or
the law and then the testimony Through
the Bible the word of God is often
called the law and the prophets
the last thing you find in the Old
Testament is there Malachi chapter 4
says remember the law of Moses behold I
send you Elijah the prophet and of
course Moses and Elijah appear to Jesus
on the Mount of transfiguration showing
that the law and the prophets endorse
Jesus if you look in Isaiah chapter 8
for example it says in verse 16 bind up
the testimony there's the same word that
you find in Revelation seal the law
that'd be the Commandments among my
disciples so two characteristics of
God's people in the last days is that
they have the law they've got the word
of God and they've got the testimony if
you look in Revelation is it 19 verse 10
says that the testimony of Jesus and
here's where you let the Bible interpret
the Bible Gary the testimony of Jesus is
the spirit of Prophecy so God's people
will be keeping the Commandments and
they'll have the gifts of the Spirit
even modern manifestation of the gift of
prophecy so I think there's one more
verse in Isaiah chapter 8 go to verse
20. yeah
to the law and to the testimony there
you got it the Commandments of God and
the testimony if they do not speak
according to this word there's no light
in them that means if they don't support
the law and the prophets
don't believe them you know there's
another verse that we have at the
beginning of Revelation Revelation
chapter one it's talking about John who
wrote the Book of Revelation he says he
bold witness of the word of God and of
the testimony of Jesus Christ and of all
things that he saw so John had the
spirit of Prophecy he was a prophet and
having that gift of prophecies referred
to in scripture as the testimony of
Jesus so you can put those two together
as well
thanks Gary hope that helps by the way
we do have a book called The Glorious
mount it talks about the law and the
prophets and Moses and Elijah if we
would like to receive the book all you
have to do is call
800-835-6747 you can ask for the
Glorious amount that's the name of the
book we'll be happy to send it to anyone
here in North America you could also use
your cell phone just by simply dialing
pound 250 say Bible answers live and ask
for the book The Glorious bout
next hole that we have is Debbie
listening in Canada Debbie welcome to
the program
hi pastors how are you doing great
thanks for calling okay I have a
question about the Sabbath okay I'm
talking to a friend of mine about it and
he uses Colossians 2 16. and says that
we no longer have to keep the Sabbath
because Jesus is our Sabbath
yeah you know I think it's interesting
that people only use Colossians 2
chapter 13 through 16 when they learn
the Sabbath truth they never preached
that in Sunday churches and tell people
you know you don't need to come to
church anymore because you don't have to
observe any kind of day of rest
you know they never use it that way but
what is Paul talking about let's read it
we don't have to be afraid of any of
these verses in Colossians chapter 2 and
I'm going to start with verse 13. and
you being dead in your trespasses and in
the uncircumcision of your flesh he is
Made Alive together with him now he's
speaking when he says the uncircumcision
of your flesh he's obviously talking to
the Colossians who are not Jews
and so they're being told they have to
keep the Jewish laws and Paul is
reassuring them they don't so this let's
know who he's talking to
being dead in your trespasses in the
uncircumcision of your flesh he has made
alive together with him having forgiven
all your trespasses having wiped out the
handwriting of requirements that was
against us which was contrary to us and
he has taken it out of the way having
nailed it to the Cross having disarmed
principalities and Powers making a
public spectacle of them triumphing over
them in it so here's the key verse let
no one judge you in food or drink or in
regard to a festival or a new moon or
Sabbath that's plural Sabbath which are
what kind of Sabbath the sentence isn't
done yet don't let them judge you
regarding sabbaths which are a shadow of
things to come the Jews had a lot of
annual sabbaths
they came on a yearly basis
they were all nailed to the cross they
were part of the ceremonial law it had
nothing to do with the Ten Commandments
The Ten Commandments are not nailed to
the cross
The Ten Commandments and the Sabbath and
the Ten Commandments was given creation
to all Humanity
Jesus of the Sabbath was made from man
that means anthropos it's everybody
and so uh and you know it's the Sabbath
was part of God's perfect creation it
didn't come because of sin it was before
sin the ceremonial sabbaths came to
Moses after sin they are nailed to the
cross and furthermore it says the
handwriting says that these laws were
written by the hand of Moses not the
Finger of God
and that was against this
the Bible says Moses took the ceremony
of law put it in a pocket outside the
ark that it might be a witness against
them he's very clearly talking about
these ceremonial laws that the Gentile
Christians don't need to keep he's not
saying that Christians no longer need a
day of rest or to observe God's holy day
so we've got I know I said too much
probably but we've got a um a book on
that we can offer probably several yeah
I'm thinking of the one called Feast Ace
and sabbaths sure
that'll explain it even further if
you're looking for a verse just real
quick to back up or pass the Dougie
saying if you go to Leviticus chapter 23
you'll find a list of all of the various
feast days that the Jews are commanded
to observe and for example if you look
in verse 24 it talks about the Feast of
trumpets
and there it tells us that they were to
keep the first day of the month so that
could be any day of the week it was the
first day of the month they would keep
it as a Sabbath rest so the same
requirements Around The Seventh-Day
Sabbath also were the same requirements
amount around these feast days that they
were also to observe but it could come
on any day of the week it could be a
Monday or Wednesday it could be a Friday
but they would observe those days also
as a day of rest it was a holy
convocation so when Paul is talking
about let no one judge you in these
Sabbath days which are a shadow of
things to come he's talking about these
feast days not The Seventh-Day Sabbath
yep now of course the book will go into
more detail and give you a lot more
verses if you'd like to receive it the
number to call is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
book it's called feast days and Sabbath
and we'll be happy to send it to anyone
who calls and asks you can dial pound
250 on your phone and also ask Bible
answers live and then ask for that gift
it's called feast days and sabbaths just
a great study on that passage of
scripture thank you Debbie our next
quality is Marvin listening in Tennessee
Marvin welcome to the program
yes good evening to both of you
Pastor Doug I called a couple weeks ago
and my question is
what happens when we go to heaven if we
have been married say two times I lost
my wife Rita
and I'm now remarried when I get when we
get to heaven will I be with either one
or will we just be all separate
well I'd ask which one do you like more
just kidding don't answer that
so let me give you that very question
comes up in the Bible if you look in
Matthew chapter 22 the religious leaders
the Sadducees came to Jesus with a
question and they're asking him they
said now there were seven men there were
seven brothers that marry this woman and
this is Matthew chapter where is that
chapter 22 verse 25. there are seven
brothers in the first died after he had
married a woman had no children he left
his wife to his brother likewise the
second also married and died and the
third all the way up to the seventh last
of all the woman died therefore in the
resurrection whose wife will she be
and Jesus said you are mistaken this is
verse 29 you're mistaken not knowing the
scriptures nor the power of God for in
the resurrection they neither marry nor
are they given in marriage but are like
the angels of God angels in heaven
and so he says that you know ultimately
when two people get to heaven we're all
married to the Lord we will not be
having new babies in heaven
um Jesus told Adam and Eve to be
fruitful and fill the earth the earth is
going to be populated with it redeemed
so now does that mean that when Adam and
Eve get to heaven God gives them divorce
papers not necessarily I think in the
case where there's been one man one
woman best friends married on earth when
they get to heaven they'll still have
that that intimate relationship and
they'll maybe dwell together
but in the case where you have King
David or Solomon or Jacob with many
wives we're all ultimately married to
the Lord in heaven and so
relationships are a little different
there
thanks Marvin good question and I hope
that helps a little all right we've got
Michael listening in actually Brittany
Brittany listening California Brittany
welcome to the program
hey hi
and your question
yeah my question is according to the
Bible what is the right biblical
worldview to have during this times with
the school shootings and corrupt
government especially since we're in the
sign of the times
well what's the right biblical view you
know the Bible tells us Brittany that in
the last days evil men and seducers will
wax worse and worse Jesus tells us in
Matthew 24 and I forget Pastor Ross what
verse he said that because iniquity will
abound the love of many will grow cold
and personally I'm always a little
discouraged when there's one of these
calamities in these school shootings and
the pundits get on television and they
say well we need more counseling for
people and we need we need better
controls and we need more police
officers guarding the schools and why
didn't we need that when I was growing
up
um everybody had a gun back then I don't
think that was the issue I think the
issue is that people were taught that
life is sacred and you do not take human
life
and if you stop telling young people
that it's wrong to murder
and if you entertain them with the games
where they practice murdering
indiscriminately you know like games
like Grand Theft Auto and no friends
I've never played it but I've heard of
it and seen it seen the videos of it
it's also all about shooting mass
shooting
and if you program kids this way and
they grow up with very little regard for
the value of life
that's where Jesus said love will grow
cold iniquity will abound and that
person referring to is Matthew 24 verse
12. thank you about the love of many
growing cold and of course the Bible
says as it was in the days of Noah so
it'll be when the son of manage revealed
and then it says in the days of Noah
every imagination of the heart was evil
continually and the Earth was filled
with violence and of course we can see
that happening today in our world
all right thank you Brittany we've got
uh Michael listening in Alabama Michael
you're on the air
good evening I'm really uh it's a real
privilege to be able to uh talk to you
for the very ask you a question for the
very first time
um I'll try to make this as concise as I
can but I can't let me uh preface
beforehand I can't promise uh that I'll
be successful as the other callers
because I got a very rare birth autism
called Asperger's Syndrome one of the
reasons one of the symptoms is that it's
difficult for us to communicate with
other people verbally all right well I
understand that I've Got Friends that
struggle with the same thing so do your
best to quickly frame the question okay
it's about uh two versus uh two passages
in First Corinthians and in first
Thessalonians would it be okay if I uh
since you all
um typically uh read out these passages
may I read them sure
for the
um that um I usually hear King James on
your program First Corinthians what
which chapter oh I'm sorry uh 15th
chapter and it's uh uh 51st verse okay
uh go ahead and start reading it says
that press and blood cannot inherit the
kingdom of God listen I tell you a
mystery we will not all sleep but we
will all be changed and of course the
uh very familiar in a flash in the
twinkling of the eye at the last trumpet
and then in uh first Thessalonians it's
chapter four and it's the third verse
um but also uh the
um 15th uh
oh my mistake 13th verse and verse 15.
Brothers we don't want you to be
ignorant about those who fall asleep or
to grieve like the rest of men who have
no hope
um 15 verse says according to the Lord's
own word we tell you that we who are
still alive who are left till the coming
of the Lord will certainly not receive
those who have fallen asleep all this is
the new international version
um I've heard that uh amazing facts I
think after a parent company teaches uh
Soul sleep and that you all got it from
a well-known prophetess of the 19 of the
1800s uh uh
ever white or Ellen White that's her
name
um I'm terrified of the doctrine of Soul
sleep because I'm already concerned
about losing my salvation anyway
um I know that this will be a period
when God will decide hmm should I let
this Christian go to heaven or um lose
his salvation
eternally go to hate why would the next
and that is based on work Michael why
would I jump in why would sleeping Jesus
said our friend Lazarus is asleep why
would God change his mind while people
were asleep if people die saved they're
saved if they die lost they're lost why
would
waiting in the grave until the
resurrection and by the way this has
nothing to do with a a prophet it has to
do with the Bible
everything we believe is based on the
Bible will give you scripture for it so
when Paul says those that sleep in the
dusty the Earth shall awake in First
Corinthians I'm sorry first
Thessalonians chapter four that's what
the Bible says
so but why would that make you nervous
the idea that a person would rest in the
grave because you have no consciousness
of time when you're dead
does that mean that we shall not
um when immediately after we die we
shall not be in either one place or the
other as soon as you die let's assume
you're saved when you die your next
conscious thought that is going to be
immediate is the resurrection
so for everybody that dies that's why it
says absent from the body present with
the Lord when you die the next thing you
know the Lord descends the trumpet blows
you come out of your grave with a
glorified body there's no time for you
but we know the resurrection hasn't
happened yet because that's future the
Bible is clear that the dead in Christ
will rise at Christ's coming Jesus said
our friend Lazarus leaps but I go that I
might wake him Lazarus had been dead for
four days in the grave he wasn't up in
heaven that'd be terrible to take him
back out of Heaven put them back on
Earth in an old body
so all through the Bible this is a very
old Bible teaching this is not something
that is recent and
yeah it's the Bible says that the dead
sleep until the resurrection so we have
a book on that we'd be happy to share we
do if you'd like to call and ask for
that we'll be happy to send it to you
Michael or anyone wanted to hear what
does the Bible say
about what happens when a person dies
the number to call is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the study
guide It's called are the dead readily
dead we'll be happy to send it to anyone
in North America you can also just dial
pound 250 on your smartphone and say
Bible answers live and then ask for that
study guide by name are the Dead really
dead and we'll be happy to send it to
you thank you Michael next holiday that
we have is Anthony New York Anthony
you're on Bible answers live
hello good evening pastors evening
um
I uh could you please explain
um first John chapter 2 verses 7 through
8.
I know the Bible does not contradict
itself but um it just kind of kind of
sounds like a little double talk but I
know that's not the case well let me
read that for everyone and this is First
John chapter 2 verse 7 and 8 correct
yes brother and I write no new
commandment to you but an old
commandment which you've had from the
beginning the old commandment is the
word which you heard from the beginning
again a new commandment I write to you
which thing is true in him and in you
because the darkness is passing away and
the True Light is already shining so
you're saying in one verse it sounds
like he says I don't have a new
commandment the next verse he says I do
yes okay well when he first is speaking
he's saying I'm not taking away the
original Commandments that you heard
The Ten Commandments are you know
specified there in Exodus 20 and in
Deuteronomy 5. says that still stands he
says I'm not taking those away it's when
he says I don't write no new commandment
meaning that he's not the leading those
but he said a new commandment I give you
and he's quoting Jesus now where Jesus
said a new commandment I give you that
you love the Lord and love your neighbor
the two new Commandments that Jesus gave
are a summary
of the ten so it's not really an
addition you can summarize the first
four Commandments in love for God and
you can summarize the last six
Commandments and love for your fellow
man so he's using a little bit of
allegorical or maybe poetic language I
should say
but uh and you know you'll I don't want
to make things more complicated but
you'll find similar contradictions where
Solomon says answer a fool according to
his folly or you think he's right don't
answer a fool according to his folly
you're going to sound like him and
you're saying which is it Solomon do I
answer the fool or do I not answer the
fool he's basically saying that when you
argue with a fool you're going to lose
either way so
um John here is saying I'm not adding to
the Bible the scriptures of Commandments
are still in place
but Jesus came to expand and magnify
that law of Love Don't Go Away friends
we're going to take a brief break and
we're going to come back and answer more
Bible questions best is yet to come stay
tuned for these important announcements
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
you know that Noah was present to the
birth of Abraham okay maybe he wasn't in
the room but he was alive and probably
telling stories about his floating Zoo
creation of the world to the last day of
events of Revelation biblehistory.com is
a free resource where you can explore
major Bible events and characters
enhance your knowledge of the Bible and
draw closer to God's word go deeper
visit biblehistory.com
every year forty thousand souls in North
America end their own lives
suicide is a terrible tragedy and while
it's difficult to talk about we need to
face it together as Christians
hi in my new book choosing life I share
the biblical perspective about suicide
answering some difficult questions about
faith and salvation along the way and
offering practical tips that should help
and encourage others
Jesus wants us to choose an abundant
life in him
hi friends Pastor Doug Batchelor it's
time to make your plans and mark your
calendars to attend our third annual
amazing facts youth conference the dates
are June 7th through the 10th 2023. this
year's Mission and title is called
identity change by beholding come and
learn how to turn your focus from the
world to the word and make some great
friends along the way for more
information about the speakers and how
you can register go to AF youth.com
would you like to know God's plan for
our troubled world and solutions for
your life's challenges beautifully
redesigned and updated amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide
straightforward bible-based answers that
are enlightening encouraging and easy to
understand giving you real relevant
Bible answers to questions like how can
I have healthier relationships when will
Jesus come and much more order yours
today by visiting afbookstore.com or by
calling 800-538-7275
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
now
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian Life call us now
at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live and for those who have
joined us in route this is a live
International interactive Bible study we
invite you to participate as our friends
around the country and the world call in
with their Bible questions you can also
even text in questions we usually take
two minutes at the end of the program to
answer questions that people have
emailed into us and we're playing this
on Facebook now it's the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page the amazing facts Facebook
page on the Amazing Facts YouTube
channel
and uh Good News television
we're now on Hope Channel some of these
are reruns during the week Strong Tower
radio we just heard today some friends
from Strong Tower radio so all across
the country and my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is Jean Ross and as
mentioned by pass today if you'd like to
send us an email question I'm going to
tell you what the email address is just
simply Bal questions at
amazingfacts.org you can email your
Bible question and we'll try to answer
as many of those questions that get
emailed during our program all right go
into the phone lines the next caller
that we have is Joe and he's listening
from Arizona Joe welcome to the program
how you guys doing doing great
hey my question tonight is
I know the Bible
um you know talks about us being
sojourners and Jesus talks about knowing
us before before we were here is it
possible that we were the heavens and
angels that or the angels in heaven that
got kicked out for going with Lucifer
and Earth is a place where we're trying
to get redeemed from from sitting
because even even Jesus when they were
gonna uh get him for saying he was
blasting me calling himself the Son of
God he said I have said ye are God but
you must die like men
so
okay let's let's dive in there first of
all um I think the Bible's pretty clear
that angels and humans are different
creatures
and when Christ says you know he knows
us from Everlasting that's because God's
all-knowing
but the Bible is also pretty clear that
there was a time when our existence
began and that is at Birth he talks to
Jeremiah and talks about when he was
born and David refers to when he was
born and and when you really think about
it if you don't remember an iota of a
prior existence and it's really not you
existing you don't know anything about I
used to believe in reincarnation and I
struggle with this thinking what good is
this reincarnation business if I don't
remember anything from a former life
how's that helping me
so you have no conscience no experience
to draw from so the Bible says that once
you were born and you grew up and
started becoming self-aware as a little
child that's the beginning of of your
existence you can read in Revelation 12
that the fallen angels that followed
Lucifer one-third of these Angels were
cast out the Bible says man in where is
it in Hebrews he made us a little lower
than the angels I think Hebrews is also
quoting Psalms when Paul writes that so
uh yeah I I don't think we had a prior
existence the bible really doesn't teach
any kind of reincarnation and we're not
trying to work our way back to Heaven
we're saved by grace
yeah the verse you're referring to is
Psalms 8 verse 5 and then Paul quotes in
Hebrews chapter 2 verse 7 says that we
are made lower than the angels and of
course when Adam and Eve were creating
the very beginning the Bible says that
they were perfect the Bible says
everything was good very good so they
couldn't have been Fallen Angels they
were pure they were holy right and it
was through Disobedience that they fell
and they were then removed from the
garden so the angels that fell in heaven
that occurred before because the devil
appeared as a serpent in the Garden of
Eden so that must have occurred before
Adam and Eve were created good point all
right thank you Joe we've got Deborah in
California Deborah welcome to the
program
thank you
thank you for taking my call yeah
hey uh could you explain the uh Hebrews
6 4-6 that verse really those verses
really scare me yeah well let me read
that and uh don't be scared of course
there is a sober warning there but
Hebrews chapter 6 verse 4 I'll start
with
for it is impossible for those who are
once enlightened and have tasted the
Heavenly gift and have become partakers
of the Holy Spirit and have tasted the
good word of God and the powers of the
age to come if they fall away to renew
them again to repentance since they
crucify again for themselves the Son of
God and put him to open shame all right
let's first take this the way many
people would see it on face value
thinking does that mean that if somebody
is saved and they backslide they can
never return
is that why what you would be wondering
when you first read this
yes I thought that I'm doomed all right
well can we think of anybody else in the
Bible that backslid and came back
or did Peter deny Christ
yeah it didn't Manasseh drifted from the
Lord for years
that Solomon was Solomon filled with the
Holy Spirit and Solomon was obeying God
and Solomon loved the Lord and then he
fell away and married all these doubtful
women and they drew his heart away but
it says he returned to the Lord in his
old age and he writes the book of
Ecclesiastes a Spirit-filled book you
got the story of Samson for example many
others filled with the Holy Spirit
that's a good good one Samson yeah he
really he lived on the Wild Side there
after being raised to Nazarite and he's
filled with the Holy Spirit and turns
back to God so it must not mean that a
backslider cannot return because there's
too many examples in the Bible of
prodigal sons coming home that's the
whole parable of the Prodigal Son
uh it's dangerous to turn away from God
because you don't know if you know when
Faith might take you and so you don't
want to play Russian roulette with
eternity and say well I'm going to live
with the devil I'll turn back to God
when I'm old that's dangerous to think
that way
but um let's read this another way
for it's impossible for those who are
once enlightened and have tasted the
Heavenly gift and have become partakers
of the Holy Spirit and have tasted the
good word of God and the power is the
age to come if they fall away meaning if
they turn away from the best that God
has to offer to renew them again to
repentance since they crucify again for
themselves the Son of God and put him to
open shame
meaning that if a person is going to
reject the best that God has what more
is God going to use
to reach them
so here it's saying that they're not
interested they have the best that God
has and they're not interested in that
um but there's a lot of people clearly
that have turned back but what turns us
back is the first thing in Revelation
doesn't Jesus say to one of the churches
I advise you to repent now why would he
tell a church to repent unless they'd
Fallen away right so he says do the
first Works he can't give him a better
work he wants them to do the first thing
that brought them to Jesus and they find
their first love
so I think he's saying if you turn away
from the best
if you if this you know the sacrifice of
Christ isn't enough then what more is
God going to do to reach you I think the
example you use Pastor Doug is is
probably one of the clearest and that's
the story the parable of the Prodigal
Son yeah we have someone who left his
father's home went and spent all of the
money and came to his senses came with
the spirit of repentance and he was
received by the father Yes amen all
right thank you Deborah we've got Alex
listening in Tennessee Alex welcome to
the program
hey uh can you guys hear me I'll be here
all right
um well my question is based on Genesis
chapter 6 verses one and two um let me
read it here really quick yeah when
mankind began to multiply in the earth
and daughters were born to them the sons
of God father the daughters of men are
beautiful and they took any they chose
as wise for themselves well I
wholeheartedly believe that these sons
of God were descendants of Seth but um I
know um Doug Pastor Doug you have
debated with other pastors so I'm gonna
do I'm gonna put myself in a little bit
of a debate here yeah um I've never
really
thought to myself why I believe that
these were these sons of God were
descendants of Seth so uh you know many
people believe that these could be
fallen angels so what proof do we have
against that
yeah well you would just have to ask the
question are there other places in the
Bible where Believers are called sons of
God and you can look in first John
chapter 3 verse 1 where the Apostle says
behold what manner of love the father
has bestowed on us that we should be
called sons of God
and to as many as believed in him to
them he gave them power to be the sons
and I think it uses the word children of
God
so the descendants of Seth see Adam and
Eve had two kids of course everyone
knows Cain killed Abel so then you've
got the descendants of Cain and his wife
Cain took a sister they moved away they
turned their back on God they were
called The Children of Men and I think
the word is Enos and it means Mortals
they were dying they did not have life
but Adam and Eve and Seth they can
continue to offer sacrifice and to
worship God and and even Jesus said to
the religious leaders they said you know
we're Abraham's children and he said
you're not the children of Abraham
you're the children of the devil so the
devil has children in Christ's time and
he had children in Cain's time
so but when the sons of God began to
intermarry with the daughters of Cain
the children of Seth began then they
lost their Holiness it's like when
Samson mixed up with Delilah it's like
when Solomon married the daughters of
other kingdoms they drew his heart away
God said to the children of Israel do
not go after unbelieving wives
they will turn your hearts away
and it's what Jezebel today have go
through the whole Bible it's a story of
that so here in Genesis it's
establishing that now some people say
but it says that the children born to
them were giants
they must be some kind of amalgamation
of Fallen Angels or demons or whatever
aliens that married humans I'd say
where's another scripture in the Bible
where you've got aliens and angels
having intimate relations with humans
that's nowhere in the Bible by human the
Bible is the angels are spirits and so
and of course Jesus Pastor Doug said in
Matthew 22 verse 30 Angels neither marry
nor are given in marriage yeah so I mean
it's pretty clear yeah Alex I want to
come back give you we muted you while I
was talking but you does that make sense
yes but uh one thing now so yeah Matthew
um there like what you just read Pastor
John it now it says angels Don't marry
but does that mean they can't get
married
well I think the point being is that
can't procreate and the Bible says that
the sons of man took the daughters of
sons of God took the daughters of man
and they were giants born in the earth
so clearly it's referring to procreation
there and why if humans are made lower
than Angels first of all there's nothing
the Bible says they got reproductive
Plumbing but why would Angels not want
Angel mates
if humans are lower than Angels why
would they be attracted to humans
I mean wouldn't every man want to say
his wife's an angel
wouldn't that be it wouldn't be a
downgrade just to go after humans and
you could marry an angel
so Pastor Ross are laughing at him when
I was young the way my mind works
sorry hey Alex I do have a book on that
you may have already read it but I will
be happy to send you a copy it's who are
the I think it's called aliens adopted
or angels and it says who are the sons
of God it's on that very passage the
number to call for that is
800-835-6747 again just ask for the book
who are the sons of God and we'll be
happy to send that to you you can also
just dial pound 250 on your smartphone
and ask for Bible answers live and then
ask for the book who are the sons of God
next caller that we have is Judith
listening in Nevada Judith welcome to
Bible answers live
hello
great amazing ly see both positive dog
and Pastor John okay if you hear me well
we do and your question tonight
yes and my question is related to Daniel
chapter 7 verse 9. I'm just curious
what's your biblical perspective on the
uh Landing of the New Jerusalem uh
Millennium but post the second Advent of
Jesus Christ there will there be a
burning Wheels on the New Jerusalem but
you know what you're saying you're
asking about Daniel 7 verse 9. oh I see
yeah yeah
they're talking about the burning fire
okay see I get it I thought maybe when
you said burning the wheels you're
thinking Ezekiel
idiot uh this is also Daniel 7 verse
nine right I've got it open he is a
burning fire yeah I know that the
Ezekiel uh describes the two that way
and you know the fact of the matter also
that the supernatural nature of God is a
consuming fire uh in Hebrews chapter 12
verse 29 I was thinking will the the
consuming far presence of God will lose
out of the uh New Jerusalem and have
these wheels there's also burning fire
what do you think all right how will the
New Jerusalem land on planet Earth
we'll do our best to try and cover that
briefly uh you've asked you know big
questions so it's hard in three or four
minutes to give you a comprehensive
answer on that uh you do read in
Revelation 21 John says I saw the New
Jerusalem descending Out of Heaven I
don't think it's The Descent of the New
Jerusalem that burns up the wicked I
think that Christ
appears in this great white Throne
judgment after the New Jerusalem
descends and every knee will bow before
him their people's lives will pass
before them Paul says we must all stand
before the Judgment seat when people see
that they are judged according to their
works then God does his strange Act and
the wicked are then cast into a lake of
fire when it says the wicked are
destroyed by the brightness of his
coming that's before the thousand years
that's the next thing when Jesus comes
when the day of the Lord comes there's a
a fiery flame it tells us in second
Peter chapter three I think specifically
what you're wondering about there in
that verse verse 9 where it talks about
God's Throne talks about he's thrown
with a fiery flame its Wheels burning
fire I think the point that's been
emphasized if you read on through the
next few verses that there is movement
that's described this is taking place in
Heaven There is a judgment scene if you
read down a little further and there is
movement so we find God the Father
moving from one part of the sanctuary in
Heaven from the holy into the most holy
place and then we find in verse 13 one
like unto the son of man he was escorted
with the Clouds Of Heaven the angels and
they brought him before the Ancient of
Days so when it's talking about the
wheels and the doubtless they they were
glorious and fiery but it's describing
movement of God's Throne from the holy
place to the most holy place for this
judgment that precedes the second coming
of Christ yeah some people have read
these verses in Daniel and Ezekiel and
they're sure that means that it's a
flying saucer he's coming in yeah
because they see the wheels there and I
I don't think that's what it's saying
good good answer thank you all right
thanks Barb uh Judith next call is Barb
listening in Washington Barb welcome to
the program
thank you I was wondering what the
Eternal status is of the people that
died in the slide
yeah are you wondering does that mean
everybody that died in the flood are
they all lost
yes that's what I want to know I don't
think you can say that because the
nation yeah well it Paul Peter says in
second Peter chapter three wherein eight
Souls were saved meaning saved from the
flood but just suppose that there were
some children that were watching Noah
and his family build the ark and maybe
they're teenagers and they thought I
believe Noah I believe the world is evil
I want to be saved by God I'd like to be
on the ark but their parents wouldn't
let them well they may have died in the
flood because of their parents bad
decision but they could still be in the
Kingdom
so the majority of the people that uh
were outside the ark they certainly were
lost but there may have been some
exceptions of young people that couldn't
make their own decision to slaves that
would not be they weren't allowed to get
on the ark
that's where God has to judge yeah yep
he knows the heart all right thanks Barb
we've got David listening California
David welcome to Bible answers live
hi thank you Brothers
um my question is regarding the sixth
commandment uh God says Thou should not
kill why was it permitted uh for the
Israelites to kill the Nations around
them thank you yeah well the commandment
and some people are confused by this you
read it in King James this is thou shall
not kill that word there in the original
Hebrew and it's quoted this way in the
New Testament is a word murder
and murder means the unlawful taking of
innocent life
Jesus when he quotes the Ten
Commandments in the New Testament he
says Thou shalt not murder so if you
pull up a weed technically you're
killing if you swat a mosquito you're
killing but it's not murder you're never
going to be incarcerated for killing a
fly
but um it is murder if you take an
unlawful life so when soldiers go off to
battle and they fight to defend their
country they're not prosecuted as MERS
unless they're guilty of a war crime
so when the children of Israel were told
to go and fight and defend the country
that was not violating the sixth
Commandment that says do not murder
and I know a lot of people just read it
on the surface like that and they think
well killing is killing isn't it but
yeah there every time we breathe we're
inhaling microbes that die
murder is the unlawful taking of
innocent life
thank you very much good question all
right we've got Mitchell listening in um
Louisiana Mitchell welcome to the
program
oh thank you my question is about
about Phil there was silence in heaven
for about half an hour
um I would like to know what is the
significance about the silence and was
that actually what is half an hour in
Heavenly Time like
um because you're going a little detail
about that well we'll do our best and
I'll share a little Pastor Ross may have
some comments on this
um in prophetic time a day is a year you
see that in a number of places in in
Ezekiel in numbers it says I've
appointed you one day for a year even
Jesus told a prophecy telling Herod I'm
going to teach Duke cures cast out
Devils today tomorrow and the third day
I'll be perfected he really taught for
three years not three days
so and by the way that's Luke 13.
so if a day is a year in prophetic time
then half a day then rather um
yeah
he talks about silence in heaven for an
hour would be
um 15 days yep about 15 days half an
hour is seven and that's why it doesn't
say exactly half an hour it says about
half an hour so this would be seven days
in prophetic time which is a nice Bible
number
the only reason it would be silent in
heaven I mean don't Angels constantly
say holy holy holy and isn't there lots
of activity and music in heaven this is
after Michael stands up and Christ comes
to the world to redeem
uh the temple is empty in heaven because
the high priest has come so there's no
intercession going on probation is
closed Jesus has come
and so this is talking about I think
that time period that's right so I have
any silence because Christ and all the
Angels they've come back to the earth
now some people wonder well does that
mean that it takes three and a half days
from from Heaven to Earth and then three
and a half days to go to go back to
Heaven of course we know angels can fly
uh very quickly God doesn't have to take
seven days to come but it does appear
that the journey back to heaven when he
comes and gathers the redeemed and he
takes us back to Heaven uh we don't rush
to heaven right away they seem as though
these things that are revealed things
that are understood there's an
experience getting to know people the
journey the anticipation is growing as
we travel towards the Golden City but
according to this verse about a half an
hour that's about seven days yeah
interesting question good we appreciate
that thanks so much we've got uh Becky
listening in Indiana Becky welcome to
the program
hello thank you I hope I can award this
right sure if we know that the fourth
day is the Lord's Sabbath and we keep it
why is it so wrong to worship on Sunday
and why will that be considered the mark
of the beast thank you
now you said if we know the fourth day I
think you meant the Fourth Amendment I'm
sorry yeah I figured that's what you
meant so yeah if first of all I don't
believe anyone has the mark of the beast
now as people have wondered do are we
saying that people that go to church on
Sunday of the mark of the beast no
they'll be coming a time when there is a
law made compelling people to worship
some away contrary to the Bible
and whenever we know what truth is sin
the Bible says not Pastor Doug or Pastor
Ross the Bible says sin is knowing to do
good and not doing it
there'll be people in heaven that had
too many wives because they just didn't
know everybody was doing it and they
thought it was okay I know that's
strange there'll be people in heaven
that had slaves like Abraham
um and that doesn't mean slavery is all
right if people do that today we know
better we we've learned the truth on
those things
and there's going to be people in heaven
that went to church and worship God on
the first day or the third day or some
other day because they just didn't know
but if you want to know what does the
Bible say there's no question the Bible
says the seventh day is the Sabbath and
people will say well don't we keep the
first day Sunday in honor of the
Resurrection I'd say well that sounds
beautiful but where is your Bible verse
commanding us to keep the first day
there is no Bible verse that commands us
to change it from one day to another
and Pastor Ross and I've got a list of
theologians from every denomination that
freely admit there is no commandment in
scripture telling us to Worship On the
first day for any reason
um they you know people may say well
it's a tradition and that would be true
it is a tradition but it's not a
commandment
if you're going to go by the
Commandments and I would think the
Commandments of God are pretty important
this is the seventh day which is the
same day Jesus kept
which is the day the disciples would not
finish embalming his body which is what
we commonly call Saturday
so what a person does with the truth is
between them and God but we're just here
to tell you what the Bible actually says
as sometimes it's popular and sometimes
it's not but we have a free lesson we'll
be happy to send you Becky on that
that's right the number to call for that
is
800-835-6747 ask the study guide is
called The Lost day of history and it
talks about this last day people have
forgotten about it but it's in the Bible
and there is a great blessing in
recognizing this uh part of the Ten
Commandments it's the fourth Commandment
isn't there we also have a book of it's
called
is Sunday sacred
uh yeah we I think we've got a sermon
book by Joe Cruz it used to be very
popular we haven't mentioned it lately
but we'd send you a free copy
um I think the name is Sunday really
sacred yeah I think that wasn't the
title of the book we'll we'll send that
to you just ask for it or you can dial
pound 250 on your phone and ask for the
books or the resources we'll be happy to
send it to you yeah do we have time for
half a question yeah let's try real
quick we've got um Carol in California
Carol you got uh less than a minute
okay
um hi pastors hi thanks for calling
um
my question is I want to have a better
understanding about the Everlasting
gospel is there any verse in the Bible
that talks about or explains what the
ever uh Everlasting gospel is all about
well that's a great question to end this
segment on well first of all John 3 16
the gospel does not really begin in the
New Testament the gospel begins in the
Old Testament that's why it's the
Everlasting gospel for God so loved the
world he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believes in him might not
perish but have everlasting life and you
can also see that in just the theme of
Jesus being the lamb that was slain from
the foundation of the world mentioned in
Revelation a couple times I think
so the gospel when Adam and Eve had
their nakedness covered by the skins of
a lamb that was saying it was through
the death of the Lamb they would be
forgiven we are forgiven by the death of
God's son the Lamb of God that gospel is
from cover to cover in the Bible that's
what happened when Abraham brought Isaac
up the mountain his own son hey friends
just in case you did not know we sort of
sign off in Stereo first we say farewell
to our friends on satellite but stand by
everyone else we're going to do some
rapid fire Bible questions
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
Hello friends and welcome back to Bible
answers live we want to thank you for
the email questions that you sent us and
if you'd like to email ask you a Bible
question it's balquestions at
amazingfacts.org and you know Pastor
Doug we've got people listening and not
only hearing the U.S and North America
but literally around the world now maybe
not live some places they might be
listening live others it's a rebroadcast
so we have some questions that come from
folks all over the place first of all
we've got somebody asking Michael is
asking from Australia why don't we have
the Miracles happening today that happen
back in Bible times
yeah well there are still Miracles today
I think I've witnessed some but he's
probably talking about some of these
first class Miracles like a dead person
Rising though I have heard stories in
the mission field of that happening or
you know the ocean being parted walking
on water Miracles seem to come in waves
even in the Book of Judges Gideon Gideon
way back before Elijah and Jesus Gideon
said to the angel what happened to all
the Miracles we used to hear about
during The Exodus so clearly they came
in waves in history and we will see I
think a lot of miracles in the last days
just before Jesus returns
okay another question also from still
down under so to speak we got Nikita
from New Zealand and she's asking how do
we speak the truth as Christians when we
are called hateful by others in society
for speaking the Bible teaching the
Bible Well Jesus said don't be
discouraged if you're persecuted for
righteousness I mean they
told Jesus that he was evil they said
you're casting out Devils by the prince
of devils they called him a
demon-possessed but he confronted them
for their sin and there is a time for
Christians to lovingly rebuke and
admonish sin and the culture is never
going to like that Jesus said if the
world hated me it's going to hate you
okay very good we got Jody who's asking
can you please explain what it means
that we were creating God's image and
yet we know Eve was created from the
rebel of Adam
well both Adam and Eve it says male and
female he made them in the image of God
so it's not just man or males that were
made in the image of God but males and
females another course today we need to
emphasize they are completely distinct
the world is trying to morph and meld
genders God made them clearly just two
distinct genders and he has not changed
his mind but both are made in the image
of God and if you think if you know if
Adam was made in the image of God and
Eve is made from Adam then they're both
made in the image of God
hopefully that helps friends we want to
live in a way to reflect that image in
our lives God bless you we look forward
to studying with you again next week
thank you for doing what you can to keep
us on the air
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]